merci
comme beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
quand je raconte l'histoire de la
création de start up artists les gens
entendent à quel point ans cartonne quel
point on a parfaitement exécution un
plan bien ambitieux c'est un peu comme
sur les réseaux sociaux
la start up party pts a l'air d'une
belle photos instagram bien cadré bien
mises en scène avec un lit filtre un peu
l'histoire parfaite
écoutez plutôt oui alors j'étais
étudiante comme vous il ya cinq ans avec
mon associé jean on a créé une
entreprise qui rassemble aujourd'hui 25
salariés
oui chaque jour on démocratise l'accès à
la culture
comment en envoyant gratuitement par
email des anecdotes culturel être une
minute à près de 600 mille abonnés c'est
beaucoup 600 mille abonnés
wisches le louvre le cnrs ou même le
musée des confluences ici à lyon et près
de 200 partenaires prestigieux nous font
confiance pour raconter leur plus belle
histoire à ce public et ça nous permet
de gagner de l'argent
à entendre ces chiffres à découvrir ces
histoires d'entrepreneurs on a souvent
l'impression que tout a été bien pensé
bien anticipé dès le début or c'est très
complexe ans pour un porteur de projet
qui lui n'aurait pas l'impression
d'avoir cette idée parfaite ou sept
associés parfait où ce plan parfait
aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous rassurer en
vous racontant une toute autre histoire
pas celle pour la presse pas celle pour
les clients celle qu'on ne voit jamais
au tout début d'article on n'avait
absolument aucun plan parfait on n'avait
fait aucune étude de marché avant de se
lancer et d'ailleurs toutes nos
hypothèses de croissance à 3 ans était
terriblement fausses j'aimerais partager
avec vous trois erreurs que l'on fait
lorsque l'on cherche la perfection à
tout prix et ses trois erreurs je peux
vous en parler parce que j'ai tout fait
les unes après les autres
la première erreur quand on cherche la
perfection
c'est con on peut se laisser vite
tétanisés par don par la peur et ça peut
nous empêcher de faire quoi que ce soit
au tout début d'article nous fallait un
nom a priori trouver un nom pour une
start up c'est rigolo on va brainstorm
et avec des amis on va se projeter et
puis on réalise
en même temps si ça marche c'est
potentiellement des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui vont avoir ce
nom à la bouche
du coup on prend plus trop ce choix à la
légère avec jean on a écrit des
centaines de noms les a testées tourner
dans tous les sens on a même essayé de
trancher en lançant un dea en l'air mais
aucun nom n'était parfait ça nous a pris
un long mois
et puis on se rendait compte que ça nous
empêcher d'avancer
pas de nom c'est pas de logo pas de
logos et pas d'entreprises créées c'est
pas de lancement la recherche du nom
parfait était illusoire mais le retard
qu'on prenait lui n'était pas du tout
est illusoire et on a compris bien trop
tard que le pire qui puisse nous arriver
c'était pas d'avoir un mauvais nom
s'était pas avoir de start up du tout
choisir c'est forcément renoncé à la
perfection et le plus grand risque dans
une start up
ce n'est pas se tromper ou de mal faire
c'est l'inaction c'est de se laisser
tétanisés par la peur et rien faire du
tout quand vous êtes en école de
commerce comme vous aujourd'hui comme
moi je l'étais en général ça signifie
que vous n'avez jamais choisi grand
chose vous avez commencé par faire un
bac généralistes pour ne pas vous fermer
de portes je cite prise a fait une prépa
pour garder toutes vos options ouvertes
et puis en école maximum vous avez
choisi entre quoi une option marketing
une option et rech bon et puis certains
d'entre vous deviendront peut-être
consultant pour ne toujours pas avoir à
choisir
j'en parle en connaissance de cause ce
qui est dommage dans les grandes écoles
c'est qu'on encourage pas à choisir à se
fermer des voies se spécialiser et c'est
un peu dangereux parce que choisir et
donc renoncer
c'est le coeur de l'action c'est ce qui
vous définissez ce qui vous construit en
tant que personne donc attendre
l'idée de start-up parfaite où le job
idéal c'est surtout risqué au final de
ne rien faire du tout la seconde erreur
qu'on peut faire quand on cherche la
perfection c'est qu'on veut souvent
attendre de tout savoir en avance pour
être sûr sûr sûr de faire le bon choix
quand on est à l'école c'est facile et
une interro alors on fait quoi on prend
des bouquins on potasse on
grandval interrhône à une très bonne
note ça marche très bien ça rassure
beaucoup les gens comme vous et moi les
bons élèves
sauf que dans la vie en fait et quand
vous construisez une start-up d'autant
plus ya pas de livre où il est marqué ce
qu'il faut faire et ce qu'ils valent
cher et en plus comme il s'agit
d'innovations et absolument personne sur
terre qui me connaissent la solution en
avance quand vous prenez les premières
start up sell un succès que vous
regardez leur premier business plan en
général toutes leurs hypothèses étaient
fausses et d'ailleurs elle gagne souvent
de l'argent d'une manière que même les
cofondateurs n'avait pas anticipé à
l'époque le principe d'une start-up ses
bases et quelques instruire un premier
produit aller le plus vite possible se
confronter à la réalité
en général on se prend une grosse baffe
parce que ça marche pas du tout comme on
avait prévu évidemment
donc on rétropédale et on rectifie le
tir et une citation du poète rumi qui
dit ce n'est que lorsqu'on fait le
premier pas que la route apparaît et je
crois que j'ai pas trouvé de citations
plus vrai au cours des cinq dernières
années
si on revient un petit peu au moment
j'avais votre âge il ya cinq ans j'étais
une étudiante une bonne étudiante en m2
un peu perdu chez elle parce que je
voulais faire un jour par hasard j'ai
participé un startup weekend c'est un
week end ou pendant 48 heures vous vous
enfermez pour travailler pour vous
amuser avec une équipe sur une idée de
start up
c'est donc proposé l'idée d'art tips la
chance que j'ai eue ce week-end là c'est
que j'ai rencontré mon associé jean pour
lui rendre la culture accessible au
quotidien ça voulait vraiment dire
quelque chose quand il m'a dit qu'il se
lever à 5 heures du matin pour aller
lire l'histoire de l'art avant d'aller
travailler
je suis qu'il fallait qu'on continue
l'aventuré pas juste pour s'amuser quand
on repense à ce week-end tous les deux
ce qu'on trouve assez marrant c'est que
le plan ambitieux le plan parfait qu'on
devait présenter un jury à la fin du
week end
il annonce est pompeusement qu'un jour
on aurait nos propres locaux et 50 mille
abonnés ont d'abord c'est drôle parce
que finalement aujourd'hui on en a 600
milles mais surtout à l'époque on avait
absolument aucune idée de si on allait
être capable de rassembler ne serait-ce
que 1000 personnes autour de cette idée
un banquier un peu traditionnelle ou un
prof d'école de commerce nous aurait dit
pas fait une étude marketing évidemment
pour essayer d'évaluer le potentiel de
votre idée ça aurait été la chose
raisonnable chose parfaite à faire sauf
que si on l'avait fait au vu des données
qu'on a rue à l'époque on ne se serait
jamais lancé et ça tellement domaine à
l'époque ce qu'on avait pour nous
c'était une vision et une mission on
voulait rendre la culture plus
accessible et heureusement qu'on n'avait
pas planifié plus que ça parce qu'on
serait passer à côté de tellement
d'opportunités si on avait essayé de
faire ce plan dont trois quarts des
hypothèses finalement n'était pas
vérifiable aujourd'hui quand les gens
voient art ips et nos dix produits qui
fonctionnent parfois ils nous demandent
est ce que vous aviez anticiper tout ça
alors la réponse est absolument pas pour
avoir ces dix produits qui fonctionnent
on en a testé peut-être près d'une
centaine et on en ajoute énormément à la
poubelle donc un conseil oubliez vos
business plan parfait votre plan de
carrière idéale allez vite vous
confronter à la réalité
vous apprendrez petit à petit et un jour
après vous saurez et si au pire vous
vous êtes trompés pourrez toujours
rectifier le tir grâce à ce que vous
aurez appris il ya deux ans aux
newsletters fonctionner très bien donc
on a décidé de lancer un nouveau produit
des cours en ligne de culture générale
alors à l'époque les cours en ligne
ça se faisait sous une forme qui était
très sexy ça s'appelle et mouk et
massive online open court 6 sauf que
sémou qu ils ne sont terminées qu'à 5%
c'est-à-dire que 5 % des gens qui
commencent un boucle finissent seulement
c'est un échec quand même assez majeur
en terme de pédagogie
nous on avait envoyé 230 millions de
mails ça marchait très bien donc on a
essayé d'inventer une autre manière
d'apprendre qui est basée sur ce qui
fonctionne chez nous c'est à dire le
storytelling et les anecdotes et puis le
format court diffusé pile au bon moment
dans la journée on a appelé ça le micro
learning et donc on a créé une
plateforme qui en huit minutes vous
permet d'apprendre chaque jour des
choses sur les impressionnistes la
gastronomie où les meilleurs
réalisateurs de signer par exemple c'est
un produit très ambitieux qui coûté
beaucoup d'argent parce qu'il fallait
construire la plateforme les contenus
donc on pouvait pas en faire un produit
gratuit
comme nos newsletters du coup premier
l'ex eh ben on va le proposer à tous les
internautes un tarif assez élevé sauf
qu'au bout d'un moment on a réalisé
qu'on avait un problème
oui avec des gens qui achetaient ses
cours en ligne sauf que ceux qui les
achetaient s'était déjà les gens qui
allaient au musée check semaine qu'ils
allaient au ciné qui étaient abonnées à
télérama ou d'autres revues culturelles
en fait on permettait à des gens déjà
cultivées d'être encore plus cultivé et
donc ont renforcé le gouffre culturel
entre les gens en fait sans s'en rendre
compte on avait créé un produit qui
faisait exactement inverse de notre
mission en fait notre plan parfait
s'était retourné contre nous du coup on
a rectifié le tir et pour le moment on
ne vend plus en ligne c'est court mais
on va plutôt voir les entreprises et les
grandes écoles comme ici et on leur
propose de le payer pour qu'il offre
gratuitement aux salariés aux étudiants
de grandes entreprises aujourd'hui comme
bnp paribas médiamétrie ou les aéroports
de paris l'offre à leurs salariés sept
petits ce petit moment culturel et ça
sans avoir de rapport avec leurs revenus
ou leur niveau de culture elle préalable
et c'est comme ça qu'on démocratise
vraiment la culture donc lancé vous
allez vous confronter à la réalité
vous apprendrez petit à petit et il sera
toujours temps de rectifier le tir si la
vie au vote start up ne va pas
exactement dans le sens que vous vouliez
au départ la troisième erreur que l'on
peut faire on cherche à construire
quelque chose de parfait c'est qu'on
considère souvent que la perfection
c'est un absolu
or chaque époque chaque personne a sa
propre définition ce qui est parfait
d'abord la perfection dans tous les cas
c'est une situation théorique au tout
début d'article ce lancement de notre
première newsletter on avait un choix
très simple soit on a lancé cette
newsletter de manière payante et donc
les abonnés payent pour recevoir nos
anecdotes donc on avait un modèle pour
gagner de l'argent soit en l'avancé de
manière gratuite alors un banquier
aurait évidemment choisi un business
model rassurant version payante
sauf que nous ça n'allait pas tellement
avec notre mission de démocratisation du
court avant ces articles gratuitement à
tous pourris
le plus largement possible les
connaissances culturelles il ya une amie
à moi raphaël qui un jour m'a dit ce qui
est chouette avec les choix c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de vide témoins c'est à dire
que moi je ne serai jamais ce qui se
serait passé si on avait lancé cette
newsletter manière payante
peut-être qu'au bout de six mois on
aurait fait faillite parce que personne
n'aurait jamais voulu payer bien
peut-être qu'on aurait gagné beaucoup
d'argent dès le début en fait on le
saura jamais y a pas de vie témoins y'a
pas de start up artists idéal à laquelle
me comparer dans tous les cas la
perfection c'est une situation théorique
donc elle n'existe pas donc pas de
pression
y a pas de mauvais choix par contre et
des centaines de décisions qui vont
succéder et qui vont vous permettre de
rectifier le tir à chaque fois que vous
ressentirez le besoin
le second risque donc on quand on
considère que la perfection c'est un
absolu c'est qu'on prend pas en compte
le fait que parfois il ya des
changements dans le temps artix ça
cartonnait c'était très bien on aurait
pu s'en contenter cette newsletter
sauf qu'à un moment il eu un changement
vous avez peut-être suivi aux états unis
un monsieur qui s'appelle donald trump
qui est devenu président des états unis
puis il a commencé à raconter n'importe
quoi sur le climat sur les sciences et
puis à répondre tout ça avec ces fakes
news pour nous le climat et la science
c'est des causes qui nous tiennent
beaucoup à coeur avec jean donc on a
décidé sur le modèle d'art tips de
lancer cette fois science tips une
newsletter qui raconte des anecdotes
scientifique pour réaffirmer
l'importance de la connaissance
scientifique auprès du grand public
ce n'est pas un produit qu'on avait
prévu la sip on n'aime pas eu envie de
le faire avant sauf qu'il y avait eu un
changement majeur est que maintenant
c'était devenu un produit n'est
essentiel et nécessaire et qu'on voulait
absolument le faire à ce moment là enfin
il faut toujours garder en tête que
chacun a sa propre idée de ce qui est la
solution parfaite
et c'est justement en confrontant ces
différentes visions que l'on apprend
petit à petit à chaque choix important
que vous faites
vos convictions vos valeurs peuvent être
questionnés et c'est tant mieux
quelques mois après le lancement notre
première newsletter
on était très content on avait quarante
mille abonnés c'était classe mais on
n'avait toujours pas de manière de
gagner d'argent
ça commence à devenir problématique à ce
moment là il ya deux plans qui sur le
papier semble parfait qui sont venu
toquer à notre porte
le premier plan c'est des grandes
marques sont venus nous dire vous avez
une super newsletter plein d'abonnés
très fidèle à 40 mille adresses email
est ce qu'on peut vous les achetez et à
quel prix alors premier réflexe super
quelqu'un veut nous donner de l'argent
pour continuer notre aventure géniale et
puis on réfléchit et on se dit en même
temps ces quarante mille email c'est des
gens qui nous ont fait confiance
on n'a pas tellement envie de vendre ses
emails donc on a dit non
pas d'argent pas de business model
retour à la case départ
quelques semaines plus tard d'autres
personnes sont venues nous voir en
disant est ce que vous pourriez mettre
de la publicité dans vos newsletters on
vous donnerait beaucoup d'argent en
échange
bon nous la publicité avec gens n'aiment
pas trop ça donc encore moins dans nos
newsletters
on a encore dix n'ont toujours pas de
business model toujours pas d'argent
mais ce genre de décision
c'est ce qui a créé notre adn c'est ce
qui a soudé note du haut et 6 qui
ensuite a fait la fierté de toute notre
équipe et ce en se confrontant ensemble
à ses choix au quotidien qu on a aussi
appris jean et moi qui en était vraiment
et ce qu'on voulait et en plus ça nous a
forcé à être innovant parce qu'à un
moment faut quand même gagner de
l'argent et donc on a fait autrement on
allait voir plein de partenaires
prestigieux le louvre le cnrs et plein
d'autres et on leur a proposé de devenir
nos sponsors et aujourd'hui nos
sponsorise pour qu'on écrive avec nos
mots des histoires incroyables sur leurs
oeuvres d'art ou leurs recherches
et ce alors génère beaucoup d'intérêt du
trafic web
et puis quelques visites physiques donc
tout le monde est content six cent mille
abonnés aussi et c'était ça le business
plan local il fallait qu'on arrive en
confrontant les différentes visions
un dernier exemple pour la route il ya
quelques semaines il ya un investisseur
qui nous a contactés il nous a proposé
énormément d'argent
il avait une petite idée derrière la
tête bien sûr il se disait qu'avec nos
quizz de culture générale
on était les premiers en france voire au
monde être capable avec toutes ces
données d'estimer le niveau moyen de
culture générale de quelqu'un en gros
ils pensaient qu'on était capable de
dire qu'un franciliens en moyenne entre
40 et 50 ans connaît telles choses ou
telle chose sur le nos logis où
l'histoire pour lui sa vision parfaite
c'était qu'on allait pouvoir créer un
test de culture générale que les
entreprises allaient s'arracher pour
recruter des gens très cultivés et
évidemment il offrait beaucoup d'argent
pour faire ça on a réfléchi et encore
une fois on a dit non parce que c'est
pas parce qu'on était les seuls capables
de le faire ou que c'était un projet
incroyable que c'est ce qu'on voulait
vraiment pour nous l'idée de faire un
produit qui allait permettre de recruter
et donc de discriminer sur un niveau de
culture générale
en fait c'est l inverse de tout ce qu'on
avait essayée de construire depuis cinq
ans donc on a dit non et on lui a
demandé de garder son argent pour
conclure chercher la perfection à tout
prix c'est surtout risqué de passer à
côté de belles opportunités de ne rien
faire ou d'aller contre votre éthique
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de monde parallèle avec une autre
colline où une autre artiste qui aurait
réussi à laquelle vous pourrez vous
comparez personne ne sera jamais ce que
vous auriez pu être d'autres par contre
vous avez toute la vie et tous vos choix
pour apprendre à vous connaître petit à
petit rappelez vous vous êtes la somme
de tous aux petits choix au quotidien je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]